[Music]
well the Hard Rock International has
officially purchased the Mirage on the
Las Vegas Strip for about 1.1 billion
dollars now the company received the
regulatory regulatory approval from the
Nevada gaming commission on Friday but
today we spoke to the new property
president as HRI takes control of
operations
since 1989 The Mirage has attracted
Millions to its Hotel and Casino on Las
Vegas Boulevard the iconic volcano being
a popular feature for many tourists I've
stated many of the other hotels along
the strip over the years and I've stayed
here before too we met Gian Blair as she
was checking out of the hotel and says
this trip will be one for the books I
was excited to be part of the last guest
team to stay here as the Mirage Joe Lupo
is the new president for the Mirage and
tells us the changes that are coming
will be major as hard rock International
share these renderings of the finished
property which includes a giant guitar
and a variety of new features parking
tram and other Resort services will
remain the same we're going to push the
envelope we have our new Unity card that
is global in over 70 countries worldwide
so I think that's a big new step in the
differentiator for Hard Rock On The
Mirage when we compare ourselves with
our competitors here in Las Vegas Lupo
says they've hired 100 people who
started today and still need to hire
about a hundred more for the more than 3
000 room property Monday morning guests
experience delays as a resort software
updated from the MGM to the Hard Rock
server we've had to change platforms
from our slot system to a reservation
system so we expected to be some down
time we had some signage already
prepared we apologize for that we're
trying to work through that with the
customers but very little it's exciting
to Usher out an era and Usher in a new
era
very exciting so far at Lupo tells me
the property name change and the
renovations including the new guitar
will be part of a process with no date
for completion now the volcano will not
be part of the new design and according
to their website major Renovations are
set to begin next year now to read